there are many listenin creatures in
Greek mythology that are so obscure that
devoted an entire video to each one of
them just isn't really practical so here
are five of my personal favorite
creatures and monsters that most people
didn't know existed to Soloff we have
the ophea Taurus a creature that is
capable of killing a god the feo Taurus
was a half serpent half bull creature
it essentially resembled a snake but was
the head of a bull now the creature it's
often imposes the power to kill a god
but slay kneel for tourists and burn in
its entrails would give whoever burn
them immense power it's believed that
the Titans acquired this beast during
the war of the Olympians a gift from
Uranus and Gaia when the Titans
attempted to burn the entrails they were
intercepted and retrieved by an eagle of
Zeus ensuring that a Titan secret weapon
could never be used our second set of
creatures today are the Tell kinis the
original inhabitants of the islands of
Rhodes Crete in Cyprus there are quite a
few stories of how the tokens came to
exist or the most common being that
there was a children of Gaia and
pontiff's the earth and the sea however
some believe that much like the Erinyes
they were born from the blood of Uranus
when he was castrated the appearance of
the token ease is quite odd to say the
least they were said to have the head of
a dog but instead of hands and feets
they had flippers these help knees were
believed to invented metalwork in
creating the sickle at Cronus wood used
to castrate his father and the iconic
Trident of Poseidon though how they were
able to craft these items considering
they had flippers for hands I don't
really know
it became quite common for telekinesis
to use sorcery to imbue the objects they
created of immense power this one and
the nickname the Wizards of the sea
however the use of this sorcery would
deeply angered Zeus and he would cost
them out into the pits of Tartarus at
number three we have imp user beliefs
who have been one of the many follows
commanded by Hakata and Pusa was a
shape-shifting female with flaming head
of hair in the earliest accounts and
Pusa was described as a demigoddess with
many speculating that she was in fact
the daughter of her karta it's believed
that she feasted upon young men when
they slept seducing them into her bed
before devouring their flesh there has
been some debate us the exact
translation of her name with many
agreeing that it derived from a term
meaning one-footed which is why we often
see her with one leg made of brass and
the other leg being that of a donkey
so if infuser was more of a goddess than
a creature then why is she on this list
in the years that followed she was
somewhat downgraded from a goddess to a
species of creature known as the NP you
say a group of demon spirits that took
the form of beautiful women in order to
devour young men
so essentially the Greek version of a
vampire and succubus they were said to
accompany her Katya she made her journey
from the earth to the underworld and
many saw them as pot vampiric ghost part
demon the fourth ritual nurse list is
laDawn the serpentine dragon elves toss
of God in the golden apples in the
garden of asperities there is some
debate surrounding the parents of Ladon
but he's generally described as being
the son of Typhon and echidna laDawn
appeared as a large dragon moved
numerous heads that wrapped and twisted
itself around the tree where the golden
apples grew the name nod on may sound
fairly familiar to some of you and
that's because he featured in the twelve
labors of Heracles now in some accounts
the serpent is described as being so
terrifying that even Heracles did not
dare to face the Beast so he instead had
the Titan Atlas collect the apples for
him in the other version of the tale
Heracles did venture into the garden and
after an epic encounter he would
eventually overcome Ladon it said that
the day off the Jason and his Argonauts
pashed through the garden on their
return from Colchis they came across the
still twitching body of Ladon not known
if the dragon was alive or dead a fifth
and lost creature for today is the
Caucasian eagle named off the mountains
of Caucasus that it called home the
Caucasian eagle was a gigantic eagle
sent by Zeus to feast upon the liver of
Prometheus as punishment for giving fire
to mankind and even in Prometheus liver
would regenerate
only for the equal to return the next
morning and repeat the process there
have been some very own accounts
regarding the appearance of the Eagle
sometimes being described as a bronzer
automaton made by Hephaestus and others
believe the Eagle was a horrid looking
creature spawn from the mother or
monsters herself echidna when Heracles
eventually came to free Prometheus he
would slay the eagle by firing a volley
of arrows the Eagle however will be
placed amongst the stars as the
constellation Aquila which is Latin for
Eagle hopefully you've enjoyed taking a
look at some of the lesser-known
creatures and monsters that appear in
Greek mythology if you'd like a video
similar to this but tackling some of the
lesser-known deities then let me know in
the comments below
as always I've been your host mythology
and fiction explained